[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello everybody
we are here it's Friday and we're gonna
be playing some Wolfenstein a young
blood but we're gonna be playing on the
GT 76 Titan laptop from MSI it's a beast
a very powerful laptop some say might be
a replacement for a desktop so of course
naturally we got to slap a game on it oh
yeah and check it out what better to
play than the most recently released
entry in the Wolfenstein series
Wolfenstein Youngblood I'm actually a
really big fan of the series and I'm
excited to play this game where I got a
chance to do a little bit of it earlier
but I'm I'm stoked to play some of it
here for you guys
exactly we're gonna actually start a new
game
fresh fresh from the start and we're
going to just kind of go on a wonderful
journey we're not gonna join a game
actually that's that's you have no
friends that was so sad
see you let's change this that we can
just not be public just do one of these
so but yeah the co-op feature is that
something that's you know a new addition
to the series yes so you get to play as
BJ blaskowitz is two twin daughters who
are going to be introduced to here in
this intro cutscene noise who are every
bit as great at do putting a good murder
on a bunch of Nazis as runs in the
family
it really does
[Music]
pick your head up yes come on now yes
we've got an interesting setup here BJ's
training one of the ladders how to how
to do some hunting no idea what it's
doing in these parts
bless the strayed from the flop scared
yeah
driven off storms I reckon storms coming
in about this can I take the shot
uh-uh it's really pretty yeah I really
kind of like the design of sort of the
the new new all consigned stuff to my as
a complete package disco deal move up
awareness and Arabic
you make sure why you're stalking that
big arm you're still watching out for
what's stalking you baby
good good all right all right tell me
what you're sensing it's gonna rain soon
good
what else I don't know there's a it's a
band of Keio it's about a hundred yards
north east of here
five more self yeah kick okay you're
also kind of getting introduced to the
keep your hands up kind of I guess
demeanor both of the the two sisters
one's more brash and kind of wants to
just get in and mess stuff up and the
other one's kind of more cool calculated
air being ruthlessly trained by their
parents I know which is being very
apparent right now definitely drastic
you know changes in how they're being
trained also survive because to embrace
the suffering just end up I mean
yourself as they've been through and
stuff that they've seen it makes sense
that has used up each part marked love
aspect language Sophia
the anger that appear the raw energy
that was gonna happen eventually
I felt it myself yeah successful this
moment's wild TJ is like oh what else do
you sense and she's like I don't know
and of course for some reason Vijay
could sense a snake on the other side
because of course he can come on out
take your shot
before the rains come
nice the well time shot with the
transition yeah I like that well she got
it we got dinner yeah soup's on success
well done
y'all all right here oh good for you
Kenneth I was beginning to think you
lacked that killer instinct screw you
Arthur girls you'd be nice to each other
so any of these moments with the two
daughters in them are kind of one of the
high points of this game so far for me
and what I have played and just any
interaction they have is just it's kind
of over the top in crazy in a way that
still kind of makes sense it's a very
good contrast to BJ's character and the
other two Wolfenstein games which is
kind of more like self-reflective he
kind of has like a monologue that runs
inside of them all the time but they're
they're like yelling and and just
running around and being really loud
which is kind of cool yeah it's kind of
a neat way to add more different
personalities and stuff like that but
still keep them tied into the original
characters a little bit of a
flash-forward here to when they're in
France oh boy so suits 20 sister's
daughter so the theme is can be didn't
best group each and said suffer a be
here surgery happening over a casual
conversation we know he was here man
it gave me he's pretty comment anything
any doctor shows they do it all the time
Oh interesting yes
might have been too much surgery no ha
ha Bolan abdomen Joe and Rebecca he's
got so caught up in story surgery became
to grass we had to save you guys from
seeing the things that you were about to
see you bring power suits
yep we don't have anything like this
here man cutscenes have gotten so good
that sometimes you forget you're
watching a game and not like you're not
a movie it's like voice acting animation
all that's come on dr. Jack good to kill
Nazis I mean they're not lying though
they don't need to know that
very well then I may have an assignment
suitable for to non-circular such as
yourselves
I swear though the kind of sets for
what's happening yes they're both taking
it upon themselves to go into still
nazi-occupied France still to go and try
to rescue their dad who's gone missing
and the last known area he was in is
Miss France we're getting this weird
like flash-forward mission on a Nazi
blimp first to kind of like break us
into it right they gotta show off how
badass they are so that's just it they
may talk a mean game and we're about to
see in this cutscene how they're like oh
we were born to kill Nazis we've been
training for this but they're like oh
shoot it's our first Nazi what do we
gotta take him out and I love this
moment a lot it kind of adds some weight
I just try to you know try to get up
close humanity yeah yeah cuz like
they're excited to save their dad they
know they're prepared for it like it
makes you kind of like stop and take a
pause for a bit ah you're actually quite
a person yeah exactly
um makes it feel a little more real when
you actually have to do it yeah it's
alright though because as soon as they
get this guy done and out of the way
they don't second-guess as a taste of
blood now no return exactly literally
we'll have a taste of blood here in a
second Oh
we got the cool 80s style soundtrack
going on position
[Music]
sounds like yelling and cheering unless
she throws up because she rises up she
didn't goes right back into cheering I
love it so much green yeah they're
fantastic I love these two characters so
much and they work so well and now
they're just like staring at the bunny
like oh man what are we talking we can
find him you kidding me we've got this
[ __ ] this [ __ ] egg
all right so here we are what a great
way till I start the game yeah yeah grab
all these computers but I felt like I
grow on it more of an attachment right
like I grew with them yeah there's a lot
of good kind of just building that
happens along the way and we get this
this first character we get to do a
stealth assassination on oh yeah so the
loadout that I pick to start off with
you can kind of build it out from the
beginning is I've got a machine pistol
and I also have the axe which is kind of
more of a a Wolfenstein to new Colossus
loadout that's kind of like do that kind
of thing
a bit to pick which sister you play us
yeah so I played this Jess on my
original once I made my second profile
legacy other sisters so I get to kind of
care more of that stuff you get to throw
up some double horns if you want to give
your partner some some armor I think
they have the the health boosts greven
grab an ammo and stuff is always got
shared lives that's how they kind of
juggle the coop stuff so if you go over
here and open one of these containers
it'll add one which you can see on the
right side to be honest I felt like you
know I have an undying like need for
co-op games all the time I feel like I
want more co-op games and this is
already pretty awesome it's uh most the
time I've been playing has been with
complain a bit with with John Luke I
played a bit with Michael I have a good
time with it this is it I'm trying to do
a bit of stuff but it's definitely not
gonna go well let's see how far we can
get in this guy he got shot off so video
game magic so now we're now we're in it
Oh ding I filled that punch
yeah they do a little bit of fighting
back
so the person's first we got to find got
there a lot never got to find a disc
with a key on it so we can get through
one of these doors so we've got it got a
mark over here
it'll tell us who they keep so just got
to find the for the code the code to get
in and then it's it's marking it back
over here for us this is kind of a
tutorial you take it to a computer to go
and crack it
so there's there's layers it's a kind of
how you got to work your way through it
to code find out that the code is eight
four three one all right 843 one don't
forget it eight four three one yeah
you're alluding to before you forget
that a four through I I actually think
they do a good job with us to it I think
it's gonna show it at the top yeah so it
shows it on the thing if you've got sue
if you want to not have to think too
much
which is a thing I'm a big fan of you
could just have the game tell you what
the code is oh that's fair when we find
out the stores locked so we've got to go
over here grab some of this get to a
little bit of a sick thing sneaky sneaky
goop's has been using a touch pad on the
last I wish that I could say I was good
enough to be using one but now I'm using
Mouse yeah a regular like kind of cheap
Mouse it's not my usual thing but it's
getting the job done
yeah sorry shadow is just so into the
game so far in the cutscenes I'm
actually really really enjoying it so
far it's like I don't think I've seen
much of the other wolven signs except
for like the super old like original
ones and you know but who hasn't seen
those at some point in their lives
but just how far it's come it's always
really you know satisfying
I never seen it like almost the whole
stream like I I love the remakes it did
such a good job like like BJ blaskowitz
used to be like the poster child for
like aa nondescript just regular dude
that you playing a game and they're like
but what if we gave him character and a
personality and feelings and now the new
BJ's like did a good job building out
here yeah yeah and there's just you know
a lot of Wolfenstein games in general I
was like looking over some wiki facts
and there are a lot of different facts
yeah
Jim sweet sweetback's might try to quiz
you guys in the time and quiz been here
yeah at some point during this dream so
people might have noticed that I just
leveled up there are RPG elements in
this video game so if you go I can this
is a good time to do it I guess we're
gonna love fighting someone so I
probably shouldn't oh it doesn't like
posit yes you can't pause because it's
oh but as soon as we clear this out
we'll be able to check it out see if I
can get like a item or something level
up do a thing muscle fatigue I'm good
alright then you can actually go into
your character and you can level up a
whole bunch of stuff you've got kind of
like simple skill trees not anything too
crazy but it's like increase your health
that kind of thing do wield is a good
one I might actually just wait til I get
enough for that and I actually took the
crushed power at the beginning you can
either do invisibility or strength I
just really like the crush a lot what
you do the I think it's called the RAM
shackles we can kind of like run through
walls into I can do that in this you got
a whole bunch of different skins you can
kind of customize your character with to
kind of stand out a bit
I'll switch it up just to do it why not
different helmet is cool which kind of
go on and off during regular stuffing
you've got all these different pep
symbols that we're talking about before
but one that I have now you throw up
devil horns and you give 25 armor to you
and your your teammates you all sorts of
stuff like you can kind of like rally
and you get to like a fighting stance if
you crack your knuckles you can half
your damage for ten seconds just kind of
cool dumb stuff like that and it's
fantastic do the robot I'm not gonna
pick that one cuz I don't want to use it
too much as a crutch but it's really
cool and I like that you can make them
do the robot I think that's awesome like
quirky little aspects like that and then
the other thing is you get these this
currency up here you spend on like
upgrading parts for your guns so I'm
like oh man I really like the machine
pistol what if I gave it a different
magazine type something like that just
kind of get out your stuff
you get bonus damage for using like
certain brands so you got to make sure
your brands are on point is a good time
cool how's the game feels so far on
laptop compared to the PC because I know
you're playing on like a desktop
yes gonna say so I'm I I have like a
laptop but it's from like I don't only
1998 or something so it's like
completely useless and I play on a
desktop most of the time so I'm still
kind of like in that mode where all I'll
be playing some like oh I'm playing the
new Wolfenstein game on a laptop kind of
in a similar way that I'd be playing it
on a desktop but it's it's running and
we've got everything cranked up all the
way to its it's on mine Leoben for the
graphics settings so it looks really
good yeah it's running really well I
mean like we mentioned before this
laptop is a beast it has two power
cables it was like boy that's how
powerful it is says to
Gables it's pretty cool surprise
surprise axe to the chest I feel like
I'd be more surprised if someone like
axe me like that make more noise or like
a more shocked facing like a Oh
guess I'll die then especially like you
have a gun in your hand you have like
this crazy metal suit but not the axe
yeah
surprise surprise me how about how I'd
make him a more surprised face and I
didn't even do it
but I'm gonna be honest sneaking is like
a good suggestion in Wolfenstein it's
definitely more about the light because
the first few were like stealth games
kind of I always kind of picture them
more is like that like it's kinda like a
metal your thing where they're like
tactical espionage action and I'm like
I'm about being that snake that kind of
sneaks and then eventually just run
again just run yeah like a snake it has
always been an action hero to me BJ is
actually here out of me but stuff is a
good kind of option to just throw it
I don't have grenades yet and that is
the thing I'm realizing but yeah you
guys if you don't know you know all the
other cool deets of Wolfenstein a
Matthew in the chat actually brought up
a great point watch the history of
Wolfenstein that John Luke did a while
back it's great very cool yeah go check
that out you guys probably will end up
definitely checking that out myself
now that I've seen more of this makes me
more interested in playing some of the
other versions yeah I I can't recommend
the rebooted Wolfenstein series
fantastic really won't put together
games great story great characters good
times I think we've got almost everyone
cleared out here these Nazis don't stand
a chance no they don't I thought they
were prepared but there weren't
you do all sorts of co-op things like
co-op opening doors
oh I forgot we got to do cool jumps
developer console is alive and well is
so about that I accidentally hit the
tilde key again all right so I think
this is the room where we actually get
the throwing yeah so this is a vital
tool for doing stealth stuff and that
you just get to the throw things it's
like hot rings right in the foot yeah
insta-kill
didn't even see it coming you got the
flashlight out because I know that we're
already getting to the part where like
the second room in here is completely
pitch black you may see it some cool
platforming puzzles going on you're
gonna run into that and break it there
we go some some cool pickups some prizes
meat Oh
oh my go up further
there we go yeah it is dark yeah they're
already starting to get you into it very
jumpy I feel like you jump up and like
someone they're not too far off this guy
comes out hold on I've got a machine
pistol why am I doing this
oh you like the effects of like you get
hit by something or something explodes
you're actually falling down but you can
still shoot but if you've been playing a
while and you think that it's kind of
like a hassle there's an upgrade to it
you can get that makes us say you don't
get knocked down
oh uh yeah I I also kind of appreciate
that there's a little bit of extra
weight to kind of what you're doing here
Aquarius asked what year is is this game
set in it's set in like the early 80s so
that's actually an interesting thing to
bring up because people might have heard
them say right at the beginning of this
mission that BJ killed Hitler he hasn't
done that and the other games yet and
it's kind of like an interesting point
to kind of speculate that Wolfenstein 3
might take place before this and we get
to actually play through that part Oh
interesting
um but yeah this is set in the early 80s
which is why we here's some like synthy
pop music happening space they still
have like the the cool like German
covers of popular songs from whatever
eras which is a thing that I really
appreciate that they did - he's an are
you embarrassed getting slaughtered by
these teenage girls live a teens yeah
that's even more hilarious but awesome
you know big boy over here oh yeah I
broke away my flashlight actually just
blind them we'll be fine
this guy
some some effects legends action is
about the same let's get both the
sisters as DLC in a bag secure the
awesome
we got like an arcade in the back here
this guy's not letting me enjoy it at
all
he's on a mission you're the envy you
know I'm trying to get my high scores in
here or bus oh yeah they got the German
Tetris
Oh Jess what are you doing Jess is hurt
oh it's the big guy circle around
yeah take it to the dance floor I'll
claim yeah take them out what your
killer yes Oh Jess no just get off oh I
got this it's fine this is fine get a
little back rub
yeah so that's uh that's kind of how the
the life system works I totally did it
on purpose just to just show it off
we got the robot powers over here so now
we have one of our lives spent but she's
down again oh come on Jess sure head in
the game get up here Oh still that but
developer consoles is definitely their
guy no I I hear you Jess I swear if you
make us wife on this I know all right
I'm gonna get over here
I grabbed this guy's gun i'ma shoot him
in the stomach
get over here
stab you away oh great
alright she's over here we're fine the
big guys still running around everything
will be okay one of these do one of
these yellow
[Music]
Oh various what is even happening I keep
this great creepin oh man they're trying
to call strats on you guys yeah yeah I
said I got the flank got machine guns we
got shotguns I've got a whole bunch of
weapons I didn't realize they even
picked up
yeah these robotic like table dealers
I keep thinking they're enemies there's
a little part of me that also like I
know they're there yeah and I'm still
kind of like like I just did it there I
look oh that's the guy it's not the guy
just being it Jess
you're doing Jess please Jess I swear I
dying
call for help out here and get me back
up
press space you guys there we go okay
jeez Jess Jess what are you there's
they're twins but who's the oldest
that's the that's the question
maybe maybe I will use the robot dance
one just get all that arm back see
killing it I don't have my assault rifle
yet what if I what if I just pushed the
plot forward what if I just ran past it
what if I just didn't fight the angry
man yeah sure
oh he's almost dead oh you got this
bland
easy easy cool totally made him be like
oh no the open or door he came back to
check on it and that's what did it man
distraction this guy shotguns a good guy
Chad asked is this early-access I did
the actual game release the actual games
out the actual game is Alan my friend
today is the release day for everything
but I believe it was actually out on PC
yesterday officially right because I
know John Luke and David played a little
bit on the show yesterday some of the
side missions stuff we're doing main
story goodness for you guys today so
yeah we're coming up on a boss right
here well right before we get to that
action if you guys are just tuning into
today's stream of Wolfenstein Youngblood
March stream today is actually sponsored
by MSI and we're playing on the GT 76
Titan laptop which is powered by ninth
Gen Intel Core iodine desktop CPU and is
running the NVIDIA GeForce r-tx 2080
graphics card it also features a 4k
panel the CPU handles a stable overclock
up to 5 gigahertz and all threads can
help multitasking without a hitch
it features a great cooling system all
with an exotic car inspired design and
MSI is giving away a copy of Wolfenstein
and control with the purchase of the GT
76 or any other MSI laptop featuring the
NVIDIA GeForce r-tx graphics cards so if
you want more information on that just
check out the description or fin comment
below to get a hold of that not bad
get a laptop and some games like you
know put some and control controls Bella
game I'm very excited for hey yeah let's
made by the remedy people who gave us
Max Payne and Alan Wake also fantastic
games like this man's invisible I highly
recommend it yeah
so that's pretty good perk for getting a
laptop like give you a game that's gonna
be beautiful on this left hook as well
just a health up here where is Jess
Shelley behind me she has that helmet on
so now I keep mistaking over any me
flipping did you see this man spider-man
again
freaky powers Britney powers oh dang he
keeps disappearing yeah he's got those
cool invisible powers
please Nazis are getting out of control
you can see him that's amazing I'm
looking like it's the big screen I can't
see if it up there's those little bits
like the smoke effects and stuff kind of
don't show through the the camouflage
it's pretty cloth aw Jess what are you
doing
hello where'd you where'd you go what's
up so chilled and crime of course some
weren't returning familiar faces and rad
and shout outs to everyone just seen
again for the first time
plants in Wolfenstein Youngblood facing
this crazy spider-man invisible ghost
guy he's got winter dreams you can turn
invisible technology's gone too far
I know and this is supposed to be a
tease when we got the ads popped in in
the back yeah ooh plus two percent
permanent damage that's what I'm talking
about and be really useful coming up
she's in the room again this guy yeah we
see you but ooh
give me that yeah it's right there
oops don't shoot your sister he doesn't
see you oh yeah just a sponge jumped
away it's right that we're almost
through his armor yeah once the I rip
then gonna be easy Jess dives woman just
just is having a rough time today it's
kind of not feeling it
yes I swear I can't take him anywhere
not even on the Nazi blimp hello hello
pretty good
oh we're taking the battle out here make
a real dramatic definitely he wanted a
change of scenery
oh he's almost done for finish him out
of here yeah yeah yeah yeah I didn't see
that yes do it
yes he's not gonna be in the sequel he's
gone for good
Bob Jones says just needs a vacation
unitards
it doesn't matter you and that's the
shiny jump off yeah like if you don't
you wouldn't have either way so you
can't go for it yeah and then we got
that that title screen :
remember all of that title screen that's
pretty epic Oh get some some more kind
of like a flashback kind of establishing
what was going on and then we'll get
into like the meat of the game where
it's kind of more of an open-world
structure which is kind of cool but nice
for now story time oh snap murca so this
is the daughter of the leader from new
Colossus who is now the head of the FBI
interesting huh
which is fantastic it's really cool to
see all the characters kind of coming
back to check yeah
GUP says it's definitely gonna have to
finish Colossus now it sounds like it
now that you're explaining some of the
some of Colossus and how it's playing
into this planet it's yeah they are very
very closely tied together for sure a
listening device looks so good I can't
get over it it's like a really good an
animating mood haven't read the covert
yeah even if it's made exactly like this
I definitely 100 MLS so Arthur and
tennis are so I gotta say to with as
much as a deal of the new Wolfenstein
reboots the one thing that I kind of
miss from the older games that they kind
of left to the side it was in one of the
the spin-off games is kinda like the
supernatural stuff as well it's times
also like but what if we turn things
into zombies and there were ghosts there
isn't like any of that in which is this
kind of a side series as much but in in
old blood I think but yeah look at the
country under a false identity about
four weeks ago but after that in the
trailer home
onion so the the kids are eavesdropping
on their parents talking about how a bj
has gone missing and they don't know
what to do to find them so naturally but
parents don't understand let's put on
our suits and go and find our dad duh he
doesn't talk for a day
just like in this eylem
I know how he is always brooding smoking
in the house
definitely the 80s oh yeah it's like
unheard of nap also just taking shooting
back shots of vodka like this probably
I'm gonna say in my mind is 10:00 a.m.
anything you can do trust me if there
was anything any of the agencies could
do girl you know I would be all over
that [ __ ] you know what the bottom line
is he doesn't want to be found on you
and if BJ [ __ ] blaskowitz doesn't
want to be found
there is nothing and no one on God's
green earth that's gonna find his ass
exactly those teen yeah and they're
their power suits he's got a family yeah
it's [ __ ]
screw heavy use for anything sighs no
scales we should got it we got that raw
unfiltered
erosion I'm getting something from
upstairs but there's nothing upstairs
[Music]
except for our dads crazy Nazi killing
memorial has been hidden behind one box
covering a hole in the holder alarms I
love that also I you could do got a
suspend your disbelief a bit while
you're playing these games it's the way
that they get the clue for where their
dad is they walk up to this this board
with all these these these connecting
threads and they pull one picture off
Blackbird Parris that's it we've got
another parents let's pick this one clue
that we picked up Enix that can go on
yes but I'm here for it either way right
what they wanted a quickie is you ain't
it to get to the next fire you guys are
weird
they're weird also the transition with
the glasses to them stealing an FBI
helicopter I genuinely like enjoy this
they're so dorky okay guys just stole
FBI a helicopter
oh and we got this [ __ ] gets real
where'd you get these power suits made
them all the Nazi generals have these
nowadays so you will need it holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] I'm so cool hey cosplayers
get to work I want to see the event
no wonder grace wants you to join her
advanced research division maybe she'll
send you to juvie instead it sounded
pretty Majesty rad do you think she
cares for another things I don't care
what anyone thinks
hell yeah that's how I adjust my classes
do instance you it's either that or it's
the like anime or you push up in the
middle big fan of that one and then we
we flash forward backward back to when
we got into this rumor they're doing
surgery to see how we got here
yeah I like the green see the blue in
school - they're both so cool
the the one that I was using in my main
one is it's like a all yellow and it's
got some of the decals that PJ has in
his jacket for today's sounds like oh
yeah this is good but there's supposed
to be a doom one
I haven't haven't had to pop up yet and
I want to have my doom stuff in
Wolfenstein so I can do my Wolfenstein
but right now they're good ones three
ones doing very well
Connor asked if anyone know if there is
the tomahawk yes noise ah there are a
few tomahawks I can actually I'll go
into the menu as soon as I get back in a
gameplay and show you some of the
options for for weapons stuff because I
probably have some points in weapons
we've got melee so you've got all these
different knives you get a cool
butterfly knife if you feel like it
the actual knife from the old blood
spin-off and you get all these different
types of hatchets like a fire hatchet
cyber hatchet you get the actual pipe so
you got you've got options they're
they're they're pretty good oh I don't
really have much to do I'm gonna try to
get a silencer nice super stealth
Accession I should have some sort of
stealth option so that's a good call yes
we do have character points so I can get
my dual wield on
and boost my armor a bit there we go so
we've got cool stealth pistols we can
sneak around a bit more and we're me the
open-world part of the game Thanks
in a little bit of everything here yeah
so we've got to find our way to the like
hideout that Pulver or resistance French
Resistance friends are at hello hello
cui coming over to check so I should
probably plot a shotgun or something oh
hi I see you me I will never change
oh dang that's one message in a bit oh
oh I don't think I hit him I did perfect
see those skills you guys it's those
types of midair shots then I sometimes
sit you can definitely count on some of
the time next maybe 360 no-scope let me
get like a like a trickshot controller a
long time ago
just point blank throw that thing right
stop on him I'm telling you they need we
need these girls and apex
Yeah right just give them all the all
the suitabilities has a duo - you like
ice climbers and smash like they would
be a console parent I'm gonna to ask you
for too much for my for game does they
could be in quite champions though cuz
quickly is they seem to pull a lot of
characters from different Bethesda
properties in oh man I love the chunks
yeah they're like is great especially if
you're shooting someone's like a shotgun
or something gotta have the chunks sure
things just feels good in us a big fan
of it
I wish I had more ammo for this gun
oh let me use this yeah
dang you guys built this to use it but
you then messed up can't expect visa
through the window
shotguns got a bit of range to it too
we're good we get everything's
everything's fine
level up still horns were good
so great she put such emphasis when she
throws it out - yeah I like I like the
the animations are good still a real
real fun time
well these are the boys I'm looking for
get out of here but yeah you guys if you
are enjoying Wolfenstein Youngblood so
far it is available on PC switch ps4
Xbox one pretty much everywhere so and
it's a-you know it's out now it's also
only like $30 which is even better nice
and that co-op mode which you know I
mentioned earlier we need more co-op
mode so this is an interesting example
of like a co-op door thing so I have to
wait for just to go and generate a code
in a different area then while she's on
there I can put in a code yeah I can
definitely see how some of these
elements are more satisfying with
someone else to play with you rez right
there you're like okay I'm just gonna
stand wait for the yeah there we go now
we got grenades ooh cheese yeah all
right let's hit the chat in band with
some with some trivia questions here all
right they're gonna be probably pretty
easy I'm not gonna single one right for
it what year did the first Wolfenstein
come out I don't have an exact year in
my head I'm already stopped
it's a I'm lonely using Wikipedia
everyone at homes gonna cheat but so if
you get these dances right then he
definitely didn't cheat
Wolfenstein Pro soon people don't
realize and screen somewhere I feel like
I want to say it's like early 80s maybe
late 70s very close very warm first okay
first you know yeah over the ladder
let's see who someone in chat says 92
crime says 87 so chilled also says 87 oh
snap well according to Wikipedia capital
Castle Wolfenstein was released in 1981
there it is boom you guys are close
definitely not not born in times we're
never playing it when when it did come
around
Sony were close circa where you said
1950 as well that would have been kind
of a relief I'm like a be hearing about
gaming in the 50s wild time
all right let's see let's bust out some
more I don't want them all to be the
years even though those would be very
easy easy questions let's see which
Wolfenstein game introduced the first
person shooter aspects of this first one
the first one is that your final answer
it's the Wolfenstein z-- the the game
that invented first-person shooters
I'm into it well according to Wikipedia
wait let me read a little more before I
gets in I'll let chat give us some
answers also you know a games good one
and scott locks it you gotta shoot off
the door oh yeah in real life that's
what I would do if a door was locked
would it be like do I do let's look oh
snap
Bob Jones got it right Wolfenstein 3d is
actually the first Wolfenstein to
introduce first-person shooter shooting
the other ones were like oh yeah school
old school run round of rooms like top
down I botched it
I didn't play any of the not
first-person shooter walking science I
could say that gotcha well there was
only two before that one which was
castles and Sun and then beyond Castle
Wolfenstein
but Wolfenstein 3d is a game that's
noted for popularizing the first-person
shooter genre as well so pretty cool
making waves
[Music]
I understand to get some attachments for
this guy
the madjoe ask is this a true story and
no it's not
although it would be pretty cool if we
had all this technology it actually
might be kind of scary right in the
wrong hands
technology yeah I I think the only
problem with it is the the fact that
Knox is pretty much taken oh my god it's
a Panzer and not just taking over the
world I think that's just kind of led to
it yeah I'm kind of kind of not about
the the knobs you take over play
technology is pretty rad yeah
you'd get more room between me and that
angry - angry pup
alright someone up there the good thing
about fighting this stuff is if you
fought them before you kind of know
where the weak point is okay so for
these guys it's all mag back on the side
just shoot them right in the gas line it
blows up ah yes downfall to mechanical
though is applause yeah sweet he's
smoking back here it's very good turn
away now he's very nimble so the other
thing about playing co-op with someone
is that they'll be able to distract Oh
God there you go
he's going down though dang it Jess I
can't believe it
Jess we got Mon showin all right here's
the next pop quiz question yeah this
one's related to Wolfenstein the old
blood okay what is agent ones real name
oh shoot
this is ellika like a spoiler territory
oh I don't know it's like in the first
line of this Wikipedia things like I
don't think it's a spoiler spoiler I'll
be completely honest I don't remember I
mean I could also have this wrong I'm
just reading it let's see if chat knows
who knows agent ones real name good
lunch I believe in you almost there it's
almost ahead oh yeah arm is off there we
go
just finally take it as a dude thing
sleepy maribo says oh god I don't
remember
you see I don't remember I remember like
breaking out of prison in that game and
I remember being like ah shoot it's the
castle so chilled says Steve that is not
his name Steve's a good guess I like it
I like work job agent one
and they really just keep come out nope
and this is specifically the old blood
so agent one in the old flood what is
his real name
alright that goop says is it ten savage
um well no one seems to guess it so far
I'm feeling kind of good about my
questions because I've stumped to you
guys this beautiful RIT agent limit his
real name in Wolfenstein the old blood
is Richard Wesley classic Richard Scuba
Steve yes oh man
oh nice shadow look at the way you're
ready see me see your running cue for
that yet you need the cup oh yes I'm
treating your glasses that Amy's tech is
on point
it's all here
like this just where are you Alysha
[Music]
well that's the other one I was shooting
I was like ah man it's really earthy got
like all of his health back grab one of
these waiting for Jess come on Jess it's
a hole always waiting for chest all the
time opening the door waiting for chest
open up the chest waiting for Jess
yeah great time
an inspirational chance
oh boy stop on
lots of armor guys oh my god is she
using that's like to the chunk so you're
supposed to use like specific Wheldon's
for different enemy titles I just can't
how many guns can you hold it once quite
a few it's it's definitely one of the
older design games were like you get to
carry your entire arsenal with you nice
I like that
never run up yeah alright so now we get
to go hang out in the catacombs and yeah
our cool friends the catacombs slim
cutscene oh my gosh they're so dorky so
great and we got snacks and we got wine
drink
cigarettes every gosh this woman's a
horrible influence on these teenagers
just let them run wild
put it down into your lungs like this
and she's teaching them I know here is
how no no no like this I'm gonna make it
look smooth yeah okay I was like if they
don't coughs OH cigars are nasty I was
like how they're doing all of this with
their suit still on key I decrypted
fragments of stolen Nazi Intel on a
computer witness reports from novices
who survived the encounter with Captain
blaskowitz piecing together the
fragmented information I deduced that he
was looking for a place called lab X lab
X only a privileged well this stuff
sounds like it's like like a Saturday
morning cartoon from the eighties we've
got to go save our dad from lab X who
knows what goes on inside of lab X got
this handy bit of exposition that tells
us exactly how to get to where we're
going that's what we got
may I have
general Lata built the brothers to
subdue and control Paris an uber
commando in each tower got the keys to
the main computers if we take control
over them we can obviously and
Chancellor eat cereal I know that
immediately like commanding steel
there's this ladies about me pewters and
Bob's your uncle
my uncle's name was too bad add an X to
and make some more cool option or drink
anything you said I was so neat joking
of course
she said Bob's your uncle and she's like
Bob is not my uncle
oh don't touch me what for me
Thank You perviness my bad I fear the
brothers may be out of your depth you
have to train before you even dare to
approach the towel fly good luck by with
it you'd know if you need any wants
together okay
the person of the bars just like minding
their own business I know right keeping
it nice and tidy he was standing behind
that board the whole time I think we're
missing something like what snake in the
grass can you just enjoy life for a
second Jess
they're great yeah all right so this is
my hope that we get to hang around in
like the seats make play safe house nice
nice get all of our quests and stuff and
you got like you can actually play the
parody game from don't hurt me play the
the Wolfenstein game new classes so I
would do too much of this well if you
guys aren't just tuning in today stream
of Wolfenstein a Youngblood is sponsored
by MSI because we are currently playing
on this amazing laptop from MSI which is
the GT 76 Titan which is powered by
ninth Gen Intel Core i 9 desktop CPU and
is running the NVIDIA GeForce r-tx 2080s
graphics card it also features a 4k
panel the CPU handles a stable overclock
up to 5 gigahertz and all threads can
help multitasking without a hitch
it features a great cooling system all
with an exotic car inspired design and
MSI is giving away a copy of Wolfenstein
and control with the purchase of the GT
76 or any other MSI laptop featuring the
NVIDIA GeForce r-tx graphics cards so
for more info on that just check out the
description or the pin comment and don't
miss out on getting some free games
thank ya
grab that key yeah I remember this style
for sure back in the day it was a great
game and also a great windows 98
screensaver I remember running an old
old computer well maybe not this one
exactly but like just that general style
of running err but uh you get the idea I
mean I need to do this too much here
crowd yes yeah so that that's all still
in there you can mess around with that
we run around grab some of these these
new quests here and
I'm gonna head back out reach the
hospital add a journal take me away
I got a rescue Marianne yeah yeah what's
down below they're both down below
underground hideout
okay
you
all right
use the map and head out just go
straight to the the first one why not
yeah and the the mission to rescue Mary
ends right there just do that on the way
two birds one stone
heck yeah so the UH the open-world
structure at this point is we have to go
and take out our access computers in
these three towers so we can find the
way into lab X so at this point is kind
of like go and do what you want which is
an interesting different take on how
Wolfenstein usually works yeah it's been
a pretty common theme for my recent
games the more open-world nonlinear
another Panzer mooned
the Panzer didn't suspect a big didn't
even know Oh God pull out the right gun
everything's fine they don't know I'm
here
that didn't make any noise at all
they're totally okay nope it made a
sound we're in it now
waiting for that that thing to pop up
there it is
[Music]
we go
get off of that I also don't like these
turrets up here you take a lot of damage
oh yes
just where'd you go oh of course she's
down she's over here right next to them
the thing I've been trying to avoid Jess
I swear I still love it so much it's so
dorky and green
oh my goodness so sound that these guns
make top tier sound in all the video I
love it
more than most things seeing that Panzer
got melted yeah
oh my god what happened
just please just so better yeah more
ammo for this less ammo for that
Shh
I'm gonna jump over this probably hurt a
little bit but that's okay all right I
have another trivia question for you
guys I was reading trying to formulate a
good one here so all right Wolfenstein
the old blood is a loose remake of which
Wolfenstein game Return to Castle
Wolfenstein is my gosh I'm gonna give
this chat a second to answer
[Applause]
oh I'm not even trying to stealth
anymore I just threw it all out the
window crying says Nazi pulls alarm
switch bin no one heard it no one's any
wiser a okay
Oh big boy that's all laser man big boy
laser man Tech I was on the best high
ground ha ha
Wow he's smart and he backed up that was
a smart AI move the knee backed up
regulation of troga nade all right we
aren't we are getting some questions and
I mean some answers in for our question
crime also said Return to Castle
Wolfenstein Connor and so chilled also
say return and everyone's right
you guys got one it's very satisfying
when you guys get it right yeah
boom good job you guys I'm turn was a
really good game it was a Rob and I were
literally just talking about it
yesterday they're just like oh man
remember Return to Castle Wolfenstein
had a kick button case but here's I said
look I want I should probably try it out
again okay is this the one that has the
ghosts in it not that I've seen I saw
about how I'm kind of sad that there
aren't like supernatural things really
the new rebooted series but
there we go
[Applause]
oh no I need the electric Kraftwerk to
get in there
you can do this dude I should probably
get like y'all like an ammo upgrade yes
I wonder if I do a quick here increase
my maximum how it heals me cool hacks
I'm into it
actually maybe I can do the thing with
ammo - yeah be nice more ammo on duty
game you have any siblings I do I have a
sister oh snap
like I'm just watching this and you know
I have an older brother but you know
suggest and was the other girl's name so
so yeah yeah they're very they get along
very well I don't think I got along that
well growing up we're great friends now
you don't even like we're way closer now
as adults but I think back when we were
both kids we were we were a little
[ __ ] each other you know and like
Jess and Soph have this awesome like
sibling relationship kind of jealous
they're just like hey you've got this
they're super supportive and they're
nice and I just got shot across the
entire zone
[Applause]
silenced pistols not the best thing to
be fighting a giant laser man with grade
nada
she's fast that way though it's too
small
she's also very small character herself
so it was like she couldn't see that is
unfortunate
[Music]
yeah the other thing that I really like
that they do is they they'll actually
like there's a like a detective book
series that they both like a comic
series they actually call each other
like the two characters in it know like
they give give nicknames to each other
for it that's it the wearable yeah they
really did make them feel like sisters I
mean besides the fact that they're twins
yeah they also look pretty they remember
being twins just like her hairstyle and
just general aesthetic but they got the
eyes face so this is the hospital that
we're supposed to be saving the person
from Oh gotcha
oh that guy's healing him daddy
Oh any has so much armor now you gotta
mean I have no ammo Jess give me some
ammo let's do one of those I actually
think I have zero ammo for everything
oh my gosh you picked up so many guns
yeah gotta go steal his gun you know wow
it's like it doesn't matter how much I
wear anything they have one it's kind of
weird sometimes it doesn't work out
where it's wanting to kill but other
times it does that guy showed up to the
wrong place yeah underprepared
is the scheme on a new engine I think
it's on the same one
he's just looking at it I don't know for
a fact though
grab this Bob Jones says maybe I just
need to kill more Nazis while growing up
together with my brother a to have a
better relationship yeah I still think
that opening cutscene is probably one of
my favorite cutscenes I've seen from any
game yes real good it's so like
relatable like that's probably how a
normal person would react in that
situation
I can't find the stairs that's what it
is oh no it's a it's the elevator shaft
literally right here
yeah ha oh that's also very scary
just in general elevator shafts that are
broken yeah hey normal dude in your
white collar t don't think this is not
the place for you the sounds that they
all make oh man that guy's so normal I
miss oh I can't believe our if dick got
him got him
take your gun Wham
right in the glasses oh my goodness
sometimes it doesn't want you to do a
melee attack other times it's it's fine
with it
say okay
homeboy are they address
dang that poor scientist I mean I know
he's a Nazi wish it's like he's so he
seems so out of place yeah firing it is
situation like this alright just gotta
get down there
scoop says we built with city dang are
you missing what AK stream oh yeah man I
I'm really afraid of the dude it was
throwing fire down the hallway but it
looks really pretty when he does shiny
care for the lights
oh-ho ain't come out of here spaceman I
like that although like enemy names are
like totally in German and stuff to you
yeah yeah yeah that'll be a good thing
to have all right
for real though take your bag downstairs
there we go
getting closer open this up oh there's
Mary Anne powered down the surgery room
so they can't operate the power is drawn
what's this hey you know we have those
two giant generators in the room next
door maybe she goes like ocean hook them
up oh but it's too late let's go Mary
Ann oh god um headshot Oh double tap on
the other you two let it gangster
killing it
see in the catacombs you got it take it
easy see you later miss you that was
like the most non rescue rescue I've
ever seen it was like he just turn off
the power re I'll rescue myself from
here and I just needed the power off
that's this fine
we also cleared the path for her on her
way out dude so everything everything's
all clear I'm set to go and now we can
continue on our way to go in maybe hit
this this tower yeah we're gonna steal
the Enigma machine oh there's an enigma
Shiina rounds
oh shoot they've the bride more men
so what's up Melissa welcome to the
stream
playing some Wolfenstein Youngblood and
today our streams hired by MSI we've got
about ten or so minutes left of the
broadcast but hope you guys have been
enjoying the stream so far watching Ben
tear it up
this wins this one by so fast yeah cuz
it's beautiful game it's not a good time
for me but seeing the cutscenes and
gameplay and little side things - pretty
good time yeah all right
dries roll back you can stay you can
stay here for as long as you want I'm
not gonna play any part of it okay I
have things to do places three places to
be ah I should
someone's throwing grenades let's do
that all right Smee go that way I'm the
brothers that away oh there's giant
robot up there
Oh ting this is Oh Dean so I've realized
we're definitely here before we should
be and that all of these enemies have a
shot they have skills for their levels
which means
[Music]
we're coming in a year before we should
Oh
so we're gonna have to run out and show
them out of the way
jess is hurt dang it Jess just can catch
up whenever she can you're on your own
let me out the night
that was a very clean glass not you boy
yeah still got the chat talking about
your acts with damn really the whole
time it was it wasn't even that big of a
win oh it was so close we didn't realize
it would
my goodness they're so beefy
[ __ ] you a chance to slay me
thank you I look over and he's on fire
we got the robots in there together Jess
gube says they should rename this game
to Jessa sir just needs help
Chesney it's out back in time all right
grab that I do like that the game has it
literally just a dedicated like props
button yeah like any time you want to
tell your pal they're doing well and
also give them like a beneficial buff
it's right there
more Albus yeah
oh there's a there's a men down here
who's running away from me it's fine
Wren see if I can steal that in English
the machine I guess soo some oh it's
right here
I found it it happens
there's Jessica and garbage trucks so
maybe maybe I should go oh no they're
all old dangerous to chemical warfare
that's not too far off of my level
[Applause]
trying to get as much chemical warfare
then in 9 minutes as we get so it's a
sprint to the end I believe I believe
let's see let's think if we could quiz
question for you guys
so I think we're gonna be going into
like like a sewer hideout or something
which is gonna be a thing sewer yeah
yeah right and real Shawshank in here
already
victory Boulevard oh snap
gotta get a house there heck yeah wait
it doesn't look that great never mind
there's nothing left of that man he is
turbo dead oh you didn't want to get
knocked down that's fine
oh I need to push him and you fell that
was great yes there's you know equal
opposite force reactions all of that
just just turn into a ghost
I'm literally running the opposite way
I'm supposed to be alright
quiz question it's like this looks
pretty good hit me with it
how many Wolfenstein games are there
officially I'll say we can include cyber
pilot even though I don't think that is
yeah even though it's not like
technically it's it's it's a VR game
experience thing I guess I'm not I'm not
shopping a bit for it so yes including
cyber violet how many Wolfenstein games
are there in total all eight for chat to
throw out some guesses I'm gonna take
just a random just stabbing the dart
guess I can try to like add it up but I
feel like 15 16 very warm
so chilled says six crying says oof is
whoa hello nice I accidentally fell
anywhere I was supposed to go nice that
works out really that the game new are
you sure it on time
goop says without googling I'm going
with nine crime says twelve to thirteen
and then he says fifteen who so I don't
know if your justice because I say but
yeah the answer is 13 Jeff 13 and sign
game this hassle often Stein beyond
Castle Wolfenstein Wolfenstein 3d oh
wait spear of destiny that one doesn't
have Folsom sign in the name but let's
see let me read the description on this
one set before the events of Wolfenstein
3d the player assumes the role of
William BJ blaskowitz I said that wrong
didn't I who is that okay cool who says
a reclaim the spear of destiny from the
Nazis okay hanging so spear of destiny
Return to Castle Wolfenstein Wolfenstein
enemy territory
welcome Stein RPG Wolfenstein
Wolfenstein the new order Wolfenstein
the old blood Wolfenstein - the new
Colossus Wolfenstein Youngblood and then
Wolfenstein cyber pilot
so there we go I want a whole play enemy
territory again brought back some
memories yeah
so those a good time it was a free game
too which is nice
hey I'm always a fan of some free game
yeah
by two German wrong place
hopefully this isn't like too much to
try and like focus on cuz I didn't
realize we're going in a place where
it's just really dark yeah fine you've
got a light
Connor gun yeah I just like as soon as I
got down I bought the flashlight I just
hear Jess getting hurt somewhere
alright it's okay can I make the jump
across to you there's a very clean sewer
that I will say yeah right water was
nice and crystal clear don't know if I
can jump up there and I can I've made a
mistake now we're just full-on swimming
in the sewer yeah if you're gonna be in
the sewer you gotta like I guess do the
whole experience there's something over
here I can grab oh I gotta shoot
something I know what we're doing I
recognize this and naturally more
enemies come out and you start hearing
them down as they do ah just get my back
oh you put robots in the sewers no one
day this water he's funny
toss a grenade toss are buried into all
those things yeah ooh
permanent damage increase heck yeah it's
always satisfying
gube says sewer juice ill you know thank
you
I'm all right
[Music]
we gonna go up here and then around
sewers are a dangerous place to try and
navigate yeah
even your mini-map looks insane yeah
there are definite layers here all this
random stuff down here it's like a tire
yeah obviously some loot okay Kelly
yes I have the the weapon for it that's
that's good things make sense down here
so dark yeah anytime I sprint it just
moves the flashlight away so that's not
the best option sprinting this will
probably leave me somewhere maybe you're
we clock out of here should hope how
much time we got left we have two
minutes what what crime says watch out
for splinter and the Ninja Turtles yes
that's the real thing no I'm gonna just
get out of the sewers then go go back up
and just run around shoots and shoot a
couple of things for the last two
minutes in a place where we can actually
see I know it's like you want to runs
you can go faster but they you can't see
anything is like a yeah there we go okay
let's let's get out of this this gross
right stinking up our suits Yeah right
back to every hole where I belong
back to Victory Boulevard by the time
just listen to me
dang let's climb up here there we go Oh
fresh air we made it out we yep got out
of the the sewers we're back in the city
and if you guys want to see more of
where these two twins go the only one
way to do it you got a fine get it you
gotta play it and today we played all of
our Wolfenstein Youngblood gameplay on
the msi MSI's GT 76 Titan laptop this
beautiful beast here you know in case
you missed it earlier it's a pretty
powerful laptop it's powered by ninth
gen Intel Core i 9 desktop CPU and is
running the nvidia geforce RI TX 2080s
graphics card it also features a 4k
panel the CPU handles a stable overclock
of up to 5 gigahertz and all threads can
help multitasking without a hitch it
features a great cooling system all with
an exotic car inspired design and msi is
giving away a copy of Wolfenstein and
control with a purchase of the GT 76 or
any other MSF MSI laptop featuring the
NVIDIA GeForce Arctic's graphics cards
so if you want to take advantage of that
just go ahead and check out the
description below or the pin comment
because it can give you all the deets on
getting those free games with your
purchase and of course today's entire
stream was brought to you by MSI so
thank you MSI for allowing us to play
this amazing game you know we only got
to see a little bit of the story so far
but it was beautiful and it gorgeous
great game obviously a great laptop to
played the game on so just thanks all
around to amasai tube in we're holding
it down with gameplay and to chat you
know we went I think one in four home
trivia questions but it's ok we love you
anyway get them next time exactly so
thank you guys so much for tuning in
today
and it's Friday so have a good one and
have a great weekend